oh [__] we're going deep today October
[__] forth [__] looking like
[__] Johnny Lomonaco on a hundred and
eightieth and Amsterdam who gives a [__]
Jack started the morning off early 6:00
a.m. interview down there in West Palm
Beach getting ready for next week the
[__] Improv I'm flying and it's all
over but the shouting I got my sober
October starter kit over at urban trees
on Ventura Boulevard I was there at 8:45
in the [__] morning I had attention
saluting those [__] who's there
at 8:00 in the morning selling weed like
this let me show you what I got I got
the ax so by October started kid but
before we get the party started let's do
another little bong hit we got Pink
Floyd wish you were here are you [__]
kidding me or what
I got Hollywood heading this into god of
being sober God of being sober that
picture there he was snorting coke later
Columbian but today he's a [__]
animal and uncle Joey's an animal don't
disrespect the soul brother but I want
you to continue me I'm a [__] savage
you know I'm saying listen the feds
couldn't stop me I gotta get sold by my
own [__] terms you follow me and today
ain't the day to do it not with the
reefer I'm bringing you this is the [__]
that [__] they gave my [__] mac
away whatever the judge after he went
crazy I'm telling you I never drank
before yeah yeah take a hit of this
calm down [__] it's gonna be all
right so what you [__] what else is
gone let's do another Barney wait do you
see the numbers I got used today
[__] urban trees I've been
throwing on [__] around you understand
me my face ain't red from the lighting
this is my face and [__] smoking that
[__] they saw over there unbelievable I
thought John McCain right now I'm
hearing Vietnamese people
[Music]
oh yeah look at my solar high school but
starter-kit just say you [__]
know oh [__] look at that organic
fertilizer that comes a little pouch
there's the type of [__] they give you
when you're not [__] around look at
that in a box what to say
top shelf flowers tucks away then I'm
showing up with Susquehanna and so
buctober something like they can call me
shorty I was born in 1940 I'm saying
it's Thursday don't give up don't give
up let me tell you something I'm on the
[__] guest book the 23rd on TBS I'm
doing something you'll never see me do
ever ever ever so make sure your VCR
that then the 30th I'm back on TBS but
Netflix comes out with the generates on
the 30th and then November 8th is the
first [__] date off the tour it's the
[__] are you kidding me ready for
this one the Tunnel Rat door Hudson
County representing we ain't [__]
around
you could bomb the world don't come Kim
could show up with 20 [__] missiles
and the tunnel rats will still be here I
don't respect you no I'm saying for that
[__] mu Tosh the tunnel rats who
opens up November 8th at New York Gotham
with my girl [__] Kate Quigley I will
[__] running it but don't forget it's
West Palm Beach first and then we go to
[__] what's the other one now
hilarities Cleveland speak their Mayo
chick ain't [__] around but listen
listen what Joey will be like talking
we're gonna smoke I don't know what the
percentage on this is but it's gotta be
about 26 or bubbling it's how beautiful
then we got the [__] look at this one
it comes in a little pouch I'm saying
like a [__] Johnny vent or a
professional this one here is o3 bubble
cush 22 percent what do you [__] kill
me or what you see that says there and
the
go premium indoor flour what are you
[__] nuts you smoke this you like
your cat you can't go outdoors anyway
this one here when I take my glasses off
I can't see nothing I can only see a
[__] coke crop under the [__]
carpet you don't say look at this one
THC 25 [__] percent limit we're not
[__] around and then last but not
least it's my [__] people right here
look at this
Nathan oh gee what's it say that I bred
like a mother [__] and this one is
that 26 percent alright
yeah you want to smoke pot with your
little [__] half a [__] friends and
talk about it you know we microdust
oh my goodness - flavour listen you want
flavor suck a [__] and my world will
look gonna see the devil on the [__]
daily all right will it smoke a little
bit of this maven that I broke up so so
you think you can tell well you can't
tell dick don't tell nothing you don't
know nothing blue skies from pain and
I'm saying can you tell this is too much
this is too much I'm taking you to
different limits on a Thursday morning
I gotta hit this total real quick I
clean the [__] bong when I got here
hot water Lysol you don't want to put no
[__] supima luke germs on your
[__] bong always got to be clean and
that's how you avoid the flu that need
your wife's ass home if you ain't eating
your wife's ass no once a month you'll
be at CVS getting a flu shot with the
rest of these [__] books here we go
did you explain the walk-on part are you
[__] kidding me at not who the [__]
is doing bong hits and I wish you were
here on a night of mourning [__]
novices gasps are you kidding me
[Music]
[Laughter]
on a solo tip I'm saying you came out of
your mom's snatch solo what the [__] you
wanna hang out with an umbilical cord
solo no [__] nothing you understand
me I don't need nobody to talk to
I can come with it my finger maeín and
get my mom a lie bingo it's [__]
Thursday looking good feeling good the
eyes are looking good with you nuts
let's do another bunny what do you got
to do I go back to work for lunch [__]
them tell them to suck your dick you
quit you're becoming a [__] you're
gonna be a magician from now on it's
tough I don't [__] know I'm just
trying to help here here we go yeah half
the year oh [__] butthat with fine the
same old fears wish you were here that's
why I got used [__]
does your mother [__] are my people
without you I got nothing you follow me
[Music]
Oh [__] tremendous I won't even muffin
give it let's do a longer than this [__]
here just to see what was sparking with
hitters as they say in the neighborhood
you can't walk on one leg you know say
you can't walk on one [__] leg so
don't forget to degenerate our Netflix
even though they forgot the [__]
match number right they don't give a
[__] but you know what listen even
though I don't think I did I did that
well [__] it we're still together
sometimes you have good sense sometimes
you have bad sets wait till you see me
in West Palm Beach you understand man
you [__] around no more I'm going
back to Mitzi [__] style of doing
comedy say what you need to say if they
can't take a joke take a shuttle
look at this [__] look at this look at
this I can't be sober in October maybe
in December when the weed like this goes
away give me a call but let's do a
[__] head of this just to see I'll
put this right here we'll find a little
bud what the [__] you think you're
dealing with and I got a full day don't
worry about none I got meetings I got
jujitsu I got to pick my daughter up I
got a spot at the store tonight I'm
rockin and rollin all [__] day long it
don't stop while the [__] is 55 still
swinging dick and giving out popsicles
you following me
well you gonna do that what do you have
to doing that I already went over the
tough [__] her a little now it's all
downhill I'll say whatever the [__] I
want to say do whatever the [__] I want
to do and we're gonna have a tremendous
[__] time you understand me
I'm sober I snorted coke ain't he not
seized and I ain't [__] snorting
heroin tonight my world that's sober
nothing you pop into a little anxiety
pill from time to time pop it I don't
drink
look at me look at that face look
somebody who drinks really
anyway listen I'm just trying to have a
good [__] time here it's [__]
Thursday you're having a bad day who
gives a [__] they gonna suck your dick
you know I'm saying you're gonna have a
lot of bad days but for right now you're
with uncle Joey we got this little
[__] nugget is coming get here and
that's it two minutes you go back to
work and you deal with your [__]
Martian friends and you go to Starbucks
and telling stories won't put Joe you
can't tell those stories you're
following me cuz I got you I got you
[__] yeah baby oh yeah it's a
complete um I didn't get my mom and I
paying their salary oh yeah look at pink
floyd's coming at you heavy
bong hits uncle Joey you can't [__]
lose on a Thursday I'm saying
[Music]
Oh [__] tremendous so bak Toba is in
full [__] effect I'm saying he's not
about smoke it's not about drinking it's
about awareness doing something
different so this morning for breakfast
what I had had my two eggs one piece of
wheat toast and fruit and two slices of
bacon s it I'm gonna go down there I'm
gonna be on Joe Rogan the dirty it right
before the [__] Netflix special
looking kid top module nothing I'm not
looking like [__] Elvis before the
operation nothing I'm saying look at me
the hair is still intact I lose hair
every day but who gives a [__] I don't
need it now 55 when you're 20 - you need
hair when you're 55 [__] you already got
your balls linked in your dick sir you
walk around like [__] Zombo without a
cape I don't give a [__]
it's Thursday people wake up wake up
let's do this [__] one more bong hit and
I'll let you go all day my life in oil
good thing might be pulled off my Fuko
wire let's do this [__] one more one
more I'll let you go back I'm gonna
finish this album and do a little
writing I gotta meet a dog about a man
about a dog I'm gonna go to jujitsu
get choked out like I always do Big West
what's your favorite move when I get
choked up that's it it's a bunch of
young kids I'm a [__] [__] I just
go to get the heart move and burn a few
[__] points off wait watches and
everybody's [__] happen it's not wait
watch this no more
but again now they gotta change the name
because people's feelings get hurt you
know you can't say [__] no more listen
stop it it's Weight Watchers all right I
think everybody change [__] names
what's next what's [__] next
anyway some happy people [__] showed
up your podcast that bucked up all right
multi loom and they're both [__] good
its conversation its conversation you're
not gonna be here anywhere else brutal
honest and from the [__] height
that's what a podcast is you a radio
[__] go listen to radio kind of
sucker but until then let's do another
[__] Bongo Ruchi
[Music]
they don't
oh yeah baby so we did the [__] mind
we did the [__] this got my boots now
the only one we got left is this little
pouch of debt which is the hybrid soul
saver I got another [__] head of this
we'll save it and I'll see you guys
tomorrow or [__] Saturday we're gonna
have before kind of McGregor look how
the reef is coming down this town trying
to show up here I'm trying to let you
people know it's over you don't need to
drink you'll need to be there doesn't
need to be an opiate crisis this is the
opiate right here that's it every day a
bonnet of 2:00 in the morning a cup of
coffee it's over you salute the flag you
leave the house and you tell them who's
[__] runnin things you know who's
running things you are [__]
don't come up to me like that what the
[__] do you think you're dealing with
don't forget the Tunnel Rat tour starts
November [__] ate at Gotham's in New
York City
take quickly is a special guest see you
[__] can sit there in the gang
not laugh bang one out in the [__]
chair like a peep show you filthy
[__] see great phenomenon I don't
know when it came on that don't man it's
Floyd in the [__] morning before you
got here I had Exile on [__] Main
Street uh I was ready to commit a felony
understand me that's when they went to
whatever and hid out because they owed
money for taxes come on man you think
I'm gonna show up T people bother you
with some [__] mama Luke album I'm
showing up with [__] debt heavy-duty
David Gilmore
shine on you crazy diamond awliyas you
just diamonds in the rough you buff out
the [__] rough edges and you shine on
you know as shine on means in other
words sling dick like a [__] you
badass savage [__] whether you're
male female ain't no woman move women
Meneses day one swinging dick my mother
stabbed her mother [__] Cuba ladies
take off the yoga pants and get out
there and kick some [__] ass today
alright you're trying to scare me with
the yoga pants on a Starbucks cup the
[__] out of here
take those shirts off get a knife you'll
see these [__] back well back
off you [__] I'm next pretty witty I
love you [__] you know I'm here
stoned having a good time getting loose
I had a big day
[Music]
kebede Carla I don't know yet I'm gonna
watch the weigh-in and then I'm gonna go
to my bookie and I'm gonna [__] on this
side I'm gonna pick up a hundred percent
of my deposit and I'm gonna win and I'm
gonna pick up you see what I'm saying
you see how Uncle Joe get uncle Joey
thinks you go to my bookie
you give him a GNote they give you a
Gino and then you but you win too
[__] cheese that's how you do it you
strike when the [__] moment is right
without even [__] thinking you know
all right I'm stoned to the gills on
about you [__] don't worry I'm
not gonna leave the angle you think I'm
[__] some Mook that's gonna show up
with a half a bond and [__] a
toothpick [__] you Papa don't go to the
job done
volcanic [__] I'm trying listen
to this [__] now they're getting [__]
bluesy on yes you acid trip you're
sitting there Sam huh well I do
ayahuasca [__] ayahuasca you do a head
of blotter acid you listen for these
[__] wish you were here and
then get back to me then see if you even
qualify it opens and the [__] out of
here
[Music]
what
uncle Joey here coming at you direct
from mad flavor Studios incorporated the
flying Jew he's somewhere minding his
own business doing 22 push-ups getting
ready to launch he's on the top secret
mission in Israel with a girl named
milkshake that's all that matters
[Music]
a little bit of water that's not hydrate
and you're ready to rock [__] I'm
happy you got to join me this morning
I'm happy I'm [__] connected with you
guys the podcaster up West Palm Beach
next week
- we slaying the hilarities a week later
the [__] special on Netflix the
guestbook and then BAM November 8 NYC
the 39th anniversary of my mother's
death I open up in New York City at
[__] Gotham like a Quigley put that
in your pipe is smoking I'm throwing
five touchdowns I can do from Green Bay
today's dad died because we take it we
draw from the [__] pain [__]
now get out there make a mall suck your
dick and tell them uncle Joey sent you I
love your state black I have a
phenomenal [__] day and weekend if I
don't talk to you tomorrow you never
know I might [__] get high get out for
you [__]